The following content is provided under a Creative Commons license. Your support
a Creative Commons license. Your support will help MIT Open Courseware continue
will help MIT Open Courseware continue to offer high-quality educational
to offer high-quality educational resources for free.
resources for free. To make a donation or view additional
To make a donation or view additional materials from hundreds of MIT courses,
materials from hundreds of MIT courses, visit MIT Open Courseware at
visit MIT Open Courseware at ocw.mit.edu.
All right, today we continue our exciting adventure into dynamic
exciting adventure into dynamic programming. Are you excited? I'm
programming. Are you excited? I'm excited.
excited. Super excited. Dynamic programming, as
Super excited. Dynamic programming, as you recall, way back before
you recall, way back before Thanksgiving, is a super exciting,
Thanksgiving, is a super exciting, powerful technique to design algorithms,
powerful technique to design algorithms, especially to solve optimization
especially to solve optimization problems where you want to maximize or
problems where you want to maximize or minimize something.
minimize something. Last time we saw how two algorithms we
Last time we saw how two algorithms we already knew, namely how to compute the
already knew, namely how to compute the nth Fibonacci number, uh and how to
nth Fibonacci number, uh and how to compute shortest paths via Bellman-Ford,
compute shortest paths via Bellman-Ford, are really dynamic programs in disguise.
are really dynamic programs in disguise. And indeed, for at least for
And indeed, for at least for Bellman-Ford, that's how they were
Bellman-Ford, that's how they were invented.
invented. Uh was to apply a general technique,
Uh was to apply a general technique, which we're going to see today in
which we're going to see today in full generality, more or less, most of
full generality, more or less, most of the generality, in five easy steps.
the generality, in five easy steps. And uh we're going to see that technique
And uh we're going to see that technique applied to two new problems, which are
applied to two new problems, which are much more interesting than the ones
much more interesting than the ones we've already solved. Namely, how to
we've already solved. Namely, how to make your text look nice in a paragraph,
make your text look nice in a paragraph, where to break the lines. That's text
where to break the lines. That's text justification. And how to win and make
justification. And how to win and make loads of money at blackjack. So, lots of
loads of money at blackjack. So, lots of practical stuff here. And we're going to
practical stuff here. And we're going to get understand see one new technique for
get understand see one new technique for general dynamic programming. Uh these
general dynamic programming. Uh these are some
are some some things I wrote last time. Actually,
some things I wrote last time. Actually, one of them I didn't write last time. In
one of them I didn't write last time. In general, you can think of dynamic
general, you can think of dynamic programming as a a carefully executed
programming as a a carefully executed brute-force search. So, in some sense,
brute-force search. So, in some sense, it's your algorithm is going to be
it's your algorithm is going to be trying all the possibilities,
trying all the possibilities, but somehow avoiding the fact that there
but somehow avoiding the fact that there are exponentially many of them. By
are exponentially many of them. By thinking of it in a clever way, you can
thinking of it in a clever way, you can reduce the exponential search space down
reduce the exponential search space down to a polynomial one. Even though you're
to a polynomial one. Even though you're still not being very intelligent, and
still not being very intelligent, and you're still blindly trying all
you're still blindly trying all possibilities.
possibilities. So, that's the brute-force part.
So, that's the brute-force part. Uh in more detail, the three main
Uh in more detail, the three main techniques in dynamic programming are
techniques in dynamic programming are the idea of guessing, the idea that uh I
the idea of guessing, the idea that uh I want to find the best way to solve a
want to find the best way to solve a problem. Let's pick out some feature of
problem. Let's pick out some feature of the solution that I want to know.
the solution that I want to know. I don't know it, so I'll guess the
I don't know it, so I'll guess the answer.
answer. Meaning, I'll try all the possibilities
Meaning, I'll try all the possibilities for that choice,
for that choice, and take the best one.
and take the best one. So, guessing is really central to
So, guessing is really central to dynamic programming.
dynamic programming. Then, uh we also use a recursion, some
Then, uh we also use a recursion, some way to express the solution to our
way to express the solution to our problem uh in terms of solutions to
problem uh in terms of solutions to subproblems.
subproblems. So, it's usually very easy to get a
So, it's usually very easy to get a recursion for a lot of problems, as long
recursion for a lot of problems, as long as they have some kind of substructure.
as they have some kind of substructure. Like shortest paths, we had that
Like shortest paths, we had that subpaths of shortest paths were also
subpaths of shortest paths were also shortest paths. So, that was handy. Uh
shortest paths. So, that was handy. Uh usually, the recursion by itself is
usually, the recursion by itself is exponential time, like even with
exponential time, like even with Fibonacci numbers. But we add in this
Fibonacci numbers. But we add in this technique of memoization, which is just
technique of memoization, which is just once we compute an answer, we put stored
once we compute an answer, we put stored in a lookup table. If we ever need that
in a lookup table. If we ever need that answer again, we reuse it instead of
answer again, we reuse it instead of recomputing it. So, we store we memo we
recomputing it. So, we store we memo we write down in our memo pad anything that
write down in our memo pad anything that we compute.
we compute. Those technique all these techniques
Those technique all these techniques together
together give you typically a polynomial time
give you typically a polynomial time dynamic program, when they work, of
dynamic program, when they work, of course. The memoization makes the
course. The memoization makes the recursion polynomial time. The guessing
recursion polynomial time. The guessing is what is doing a brute-force search.
is what is doing a brute-force search. And magically, it all works.
And magically, it all works. If you're careful.
If you're careful. Um another perspective,
Um another perspective, kind of an orthogonal perspective, or
kind of an orthogonal perspective, or another way of thinking about it, which
another way of thinking about it, which I think should be comfortable for you,
I think should be comfortable for you, because we spent a lot of time doing
because we spent a lot of time doing shortest paths
shortest paths and expressing problems that we care
and expressing problems that we care about in terms of shortest paths, even
about in terms of shortest paths, even if they don't look like it at first
if they don't look like it at first glance.
glance. Dynamic programming, in some sense, is
Dynamic programming, in some sense, is always computing shortest paths in a
always computing shortest paths in a DAG.
DAG. So, you have some problem you want to
So, you have some problem you want to solve, like you have text you want to
solve, like you have text you want to split it up into lines, so it looks nice
split it up into lines, so it looks nice in a paragraph.
in a paragraph. Um
Um You express that problem somehow as a
You express that problem somehow as a directed acyclic graph.
directed acyclic graph. And then we know how to compute shortest
And then we know how to compute shortest paths in directed acyclic graphs in
paths in directed acyclic graphs in linear time. And that's basically what
linear time. And that's basically what dynamic programming is doing. I haven't
dynamic programming is doing. I haven't I didn't realize this until last week.
I didn't realize this until last week. So, this is a new perspective. It's an
So, this is a new perspective. It's an experimental perspective, but I think
experimental perspective, but I think it's helpful. It's actually dynamic
it's helpful. It's actually dynamic programming is not that new.
programming is not that new. It's all about how to be clever in
It's all about how to be clever in setting up that DAG. But in the end, the
setting up that DAG. But in the end, the algorithm is very simple.
algorithm is very simple. Okay? And then we had this other
Okay? And then we had this other perspective, uh or not back back to this
perspective, uh or not back back to this perspective, I guess. Um in general, we
perspective, I guess. Um in general, we have the real problem we want to solve,
have the real problem we want to solve, we
we generalize it in some sense by
generalize it in some sense by considering lots of different
considering lots of different subproblems that we might care about.
subproblems that we might care about. Like with Fibonacci, we had the nth
Like with Fibonacci, we had the nth Fibonacci number. We wanted to uh we
Fibonacci number. We wanted to uh we really just wanted the nth Fibonacci
really just wanted the nth Fibonacci number, but along the way we're going to
number, but along the way we're going to compute all F1 up to Fn. So, those are
compute all F1 up to Fn. So, those are our subproblems.
our subproblems. And if we compute the amount of time we
And if we compute the amount of time we need to solve each subproblem,
need to solve each subproblem, and multiply that by the number of
and multiply that by the number of subproblems, we get the total time
subproblems, we get the total time required by the algorithm. This is a
required by the algorithm. This is a general
general true fact. Uh and the fun part here is
true fact. Uh and the fun part here is we get to treat any recursive calls in
we get to treat any recursive calls in this recursion
this recursion as free, as constant time.
as free, as constant time. Because we really only pay for it the
Because we really only pay for it the first time, that's counted out here. The
first time, that's counted out here. The second time we call it, it's already
second time we call it, it's already memoized, so we don't have to pay for
memoized, so we don't have to pay for it.
it. So, this is in some sense an
So, this is in some sense an amortization, if you remember
amortization, if you remember amortization from table doubling.
amortization from table doubling. Uh we're just changing around when we
Uh we're just changing around when we count the cost of each subproblem, and
count the cost of each subproblem, and then this is the total running time.
then this is the total running time. Okay. So, that's the spirit uh we saw
Okay. So, that's the spirit uh we saw already. I'm going to give you the five
already. I'm going to give you the five general steps, and then we're going to
general steps, and then we're going to apply them to two new problems.
apply them to two new problems. So,
So, five easy
five easy steps
steps to dynamic program.
Unfortunately, these are not necessarily sequential steps. They're a little bit
sequential steps. They're a little bit interdependent, and so easy should be in
interdependent, and so easy should be in quotes.
quotes. This is how you This is how you
This is how you This is how you would express a dynamic program, in some
would express a dynamic program, in some sense, how you would invent one.
sense, how you would invent one. When in particular, how you would
When in particular, how you would explain one.
explain one. Okay, there Let's Let me get to the main
Okay, there Let's Let me get to the main steps first.
First step is to figure out what your subproblems are going to be.
subproblems are going to be. Second part is to guess something.
Second part is to guess something. Third step
Third step is to
relate subproblem solutions, usually with a recurrence.
with a recurrence. I guess always with the recurrence.
Fourth step is to actually build an algorithm.
And we saw two ways to do that last time. One was to use recursion and
time. One was to use recursion and memoization, which is the way I like to
memoization, which is the way I like to think about it. But if you prefer,
think about it. But if you prefer, you can
you can follow the bottom-up approach.
follow the bottom-up approach. And usually, that's called
And usually, that's called building a table.
And that was basically to turn our recursion and memoization, which is kind
recursion and memoization, which is kind of fancy, into a bunch of for loops,
of fancy, into a bunch of for loops, which is pretty simple. And this is
which is pretty simple. And this is going to be prac- more practical,
going to be prac- more practical, faster, and so on. And depending on your
faster, and so on. And depending on your preference, one of them is more
preference, one of them is more intuitive than the other. But it doesn't
intuitive than the other. But it doesn't matter. They have the same running time.
More or less. In the worst case. Um
Okay. Then the fifth step
Then the fifth step is to solve the original problem.
All right. So, we've sort of seen this before. In
So, we've sort of seen this before. In fact, I have over here a convenient
fact, I have over here a convenient table.
It's called cheating. The two problems we saw last time,
The two problems we saw last time, Fibonacci numbers and shortest paths.
Fibonacci numbers and shortest paths. And I've got steps 1 2 3 4. I ran out of
And I've got steps 1 2 3 4. I ran out of room, so I didn't write five yet. But
room, so I didn't write five yet. But we'll get there.
we'll get there. So, what are our subproblems? Well, uh
So, what are our subproblems? Well, uh for Fibonacci, they were F1 through Fn.
for Fibonacci, they were F1 through Fn. So, there were n different subproblems.
So, there were n different subproblems. And in general, because of this formula,
And in general, because of this formula, we want to count how many subproblems
we want to count how many subproblems are there.
are there. So,
number of subproblems is This is sort of what we need to do algorithmically, and
what we need to do algorithmically, and then for analysis, we want to count
then for analysis, we want to count number of subproblems for step one. And
number of subproblems for step one. And so, for Fibonacci, there were n of them.
so, for Fibonacci, there were n of them. For shortest paths, we had we defined
For shortest paths, we had we defined this delta sub k
this delta sub k of sv. This was the shortest path from s
of sv. This was the shortest path from s to v that uses at most k edges. That was
to v that uses at most k edges. That was sort of what Bellman-Ford was doing.
sort of what Bellman-Ford was doing. And uh the number of different
And uh the number of different subproblems here was v squared, because
subproblems here was v squared, because we had to do this for every vertex v,
we had to do this for every vertex v, and we had to do it for every value of k
and we had to do it for every value of k between 0 and v minus 1. V minus 1 was
between 0 and v minus 1. V minus 1 was the number of rounds we need in
the number of rounds we need in Bellman-Ford.
Bellman-Ford. So, it's it's v times v different
So, it's it's v times v different subproblems. V squared of them.
subproblems. V squared of them. Okay, second thing was we wanted to
Okay, second thing was we wanted to solve our problem,
solve our problem, and we do that
and we do that by guessing some feature of the
by guessing some feature of the solution. In Fibonacci, there was no
solution. In Fibonacci, there was no guessing. So, the number of different
guessing. So, the number of different choices for your guess is one. There's
choices for your guess is one. There's nothing There's only one choice,
nothing There's only one choice, which is to do nothing.
which is to do nothing. Um and for shortest paths, what we
Um and for shortest paths, what we guessed was Well, we we we know we're
guessed was Well, we we we know we're looking for some path from S to V. Let's
looking for some path from S to V. Let's guess what the last edge is.
guess what the last edge is. There's some last edge
There's some last edge from U to V,
from U to V, assuming the path has more than one edge
assuming the path has more than one edge or more than zero edges.
or more than zero edges. Uh what could that edge possibly be?
Uh what could that edge possibly be? Well, it's some incoming edge to V.
Well, it's some incoming edge to V. So, there's going to be in degree of V
So, there's going to be in degree of V different choices for that.
different choices for that. And to account for the case that that's
And to account for the case that that's zero, we do a plus one. But it's not a
zero, we do a plus one. But it's not a big deal.
big deal. So, um
So, um that was the number of different
that was the number of different choices. In general, if we're going to
choices. In general, if we're going to guess something, we need to write down
guess something, we need to write down the number of
the number of choices
choices for the guess.
for the guess. How many different possibilities are
How many different possibilities are there?
there? That's our analysis.
That's our analysis. Okay. The next thing is the recurrence.
Okay. The next thing is the recurrence. That's step three. We want to relate all
That's step three. We want to relate all the sub problem solutions to each other.
the sub problem solutions to each other. For Fibonacci, that's the definition of
For Fibonacci, that's the definition of Fibonacci number, so it's really easy.
Fibonacci number, so it's really easy. Uh for shortest paths,
Uh for shortest paths, we wrote this min.
we wrote this min. In general, typically it's a min or a
In general, typically it's a min or a max, whatever you're trying to solve.
max, whatever you're trying to solve. Here we're doing shortest paths.
Here we're doing shortest paths. You could do longest paths in the same
You could do longest paths in the same way.
way. Uh so, you compute a min of delta sub SK
Uh so, you compute a min of delta sub SK minus one of SU. The idea is we want to
minus one of SU. The idea is we want to compute this part
compute this part of the path,
of the path, the S to U part, and we know that has
the S to U part, and we know that has one fewer edge because we just guessed
one fewer edge because we just guessed what the last edge was.
what the last edge was. Except we don't really know what the
Except we don't really know what the last edge was, so we have to try them
last edge was, so we have to try them all. We try all the incoming edges into
all. We try all the incoming edges into V.
V. That's this part.
That's this part. And for each of them we compute uh I
And for each of them we compute uh I forgot something here. This should This
forgot something here. This should This is the cost of the first part of the
is the cost of the first part of the path. Then I also need to do plus the
path. Then I also need to do plus the weight of the UV edge.
weight of the UV edge. That will be the total
That will be the total cost of that path. You add those up. You
cost of that path. You add those up. You do it for every incoming edge. That is
do it for every incoming edge. That is in some sense considering all possible
in some sense considering all possible paths.
paths. Assuming you find the shortest path from
Assuming you find the shortest path from S to U, that's going to be the best way
S to U, that's going to be the best way to get there. And then you some edge
to get there. And then you some edge from U to V.
from U to V. Uh you know, for some choice of U, this
Uh you know, for some choice of U, this will try all of them. So, it's really
will try all of them. So, it's really trying all the possibilities. So, it's
trying all the possibilities. So, it's pretty clear this is correct
pretty clear this is correct if there are no negative weight cycles.
if there are no negative weight cycles. You have to prove some things. We've
You have to prove some things. We've already proved them.
already proved them. It's just slow,
It's just slow, but once you add memorization, it's
but once you add memorization, it's fast.
fast. Um now, how long does it take to
Um now, how long does it take to evaluate this recurrence? Constant time
evaluate this recurrence? Constant time if you don't count the recursive calls
if you don't count the recursive calls or count them as constant. Over here,
or count them as constant. Over here, we're taking a min over in degree of V
we're taking a min over in degree of V things, so we have to pay in degree of V
things, so we have to pay in degree of V time.
time. Again, counting the recursions as free,
Again, counting the recursions as free, but for each one of them we have to do
but for each one of them we have to do an addition. So, it's constant work per
an addition. So, it's constant work per per guess.
per guess. And this is quite common. Often the
And this is quite common. Often the number of guesses and the running time
number of guesses and the running time per sub problem are the same up to
per sub problem are the same up to constant factors. Sometimes they're
constant factors. Sometimes they're different. We'll see some examples
different. We'll see some examples today.
today. Okay, step four.
Okay, step four. Uh let's see. So, here we evaluate the
Uh let's see. So, here we evaluate the time
time per sub problem. That's Once you have
per sub problem. That's Once you have the recurrence, that becomes clear. You
the recurrence, that becomes clear. You want to make sure that's polynomial.
want to make sure that's polynomial. Often these are the same.
And then we either recurse and memoize or build a
we either recurse and memoize or build a DP table. I'm not going to write those.
DP table. I'm not going to write those. We did it for Fibonacci last time.
We did it for Fibonacci last time. Shortest paths pretty easy.
Shortest paths pretty easy. Um and
Um and in general, what we need to check here
is that the sub problem uh recurrence
uh recurrence is acyclic.
In other words, that it has a topological order.
topological order. So, we can use topological sort.
So, we can use topological sort. We don't actually use topological sort
We don't actually use topological sort algorithm usually. You can just think
algorithm usually. You can just think about it.
about it. Uh in the case of Fibonacci numbers,
Uh in the case of Fibonacci numbers, it's clear you want to start with the
it's clear you want to start with the smallest one and end up with the biggest
smallest one and end up with the biggest one. You can't do the reverse cuz then
one. You can't do the reverse cuz then when you're trying to compute the nth,
when you're trying to compute the nth, you don't have the ones you need, n
you don't have the ones you need, n minus one and n minus two.
minus one and n minus two. But if you do it in this order, you
But if you do it in this order, you always have the one you need by the time
always have the one you need by the time you get there. In general, there's a DAG
you get there. In general, there's a DAG there, and for Fibonacci, it was
like this. Every node depends on the previous and the second previous.
previous and the second previous. But you just choose a topological order,
But you just choose a topological order, which is here left to right, and you're
which is here left to right, and you're golden.
golden. And these are actually the for loops you
And these are actually the for loops you get in the bottom-up DP.
get in the bottom-up DP. For shortest paths, you have to think a
For shortest paths, you have to think a little bit. You have to do the for loop
little bit. You have to do the for loop over K on the outside, the for loop over
over K on the outside, the for loop over V on the inside. The reverse does not
V on the inside. The reverse does not work.
work. Okay, I won't go through that, but we
Okay, I won't go through that, but we drew the DAG last time.
drew the DAG last time. And
And that's the main thing you need to do
that's the main thing you need to do here. And then, of course, you use this
here. And then, of course, you use this formula
formula to compute the overall running time,
to compute the overall running time, which is just multiplying
which is just multiplying this quantity
this quantity with this quantity.
Uh then there's this one last step that usually isn't that big a deal, but you
usually isn't that big a deal, but you have to think about it. You need to make
have to think about it. You need to make sure that the problem you actually cared
sure that the problem you actually cared about solving gets solved.
about solving gets solved. In the case of Fibonacci and shortest
In the case of Fibonacci and shortest paths, this is pretty clear.
paths, this is pretty clear. I didn't write it.
We can go down here. Uh
Uh solve the original problem.
Fibonacci, it is Fn, and this is one of our sub problems. So, if we solve all of
our sub problems. So, if we solve all of them, we're done. For shortest paths,
them, we're done. For shortest paths, it's basically delta sub
it's basically delta sub V minus one of SV
V minus one of SV for all
for all V. That's single source shortest paths,
V. That's single source shortest paths, and by our Bellman-Ford analysis, that
and by our Bellman-Ford analysis, that gives us the right shortest paths if
gives us the right shortest paths if there are no negative weight cycles. And
there are no negative weight cycles. And sometimes this requires extra time
sometimes this requires extra time to combine your solutions to get the
to combine your solutions to get the real thing. Here, of course, we just
real thing. Here, of course, we just have the answers,
have the answers, so writing them down does not take very
so writing them down does not take very long.
long. So, the the dominant running time,
So, the the dominant running time, which I didn't write, should should have
which I didn't write, should should have written it under four here.
written it under four here. This ends up being n.
This ends up being n. This ends up being VE.
Okay, I don't want to spend more time on those examples. Let's go to new things.
So, first problem we're going to look at today is text
we're going to look at today is text justification.
And the informal statement of this problem
problem is you get You're given some text, which
is you get You're given some text, which means a string, a whole bunch of
means a string, a whole bunch of characters.
characters. Uh
Uh And we want to split them into good
And we want to split them into good lines.
Okay, the rules of the game here are we're going to like in the early
we're going to like in the early lectures of document distance, we have
lectures of document distance, we have some definition of splitting a document
some definition of splitting a document into words separated by spaces.
into words separated by spaces. And what we want to do is cut We can
And what we want to do is cut We can only cut between word boundaries.
only cut between word boundaries. And we want to
And we want to uh you know, write some text. It can
uh you know, write some text. It can have some spaces in it. Then there's a
have some spaces in it. Then there's a new line.
Something like that. We'd like to avoid And we want to
We'd like to avoid And we want to justify our text on the right here.
justify our text on the right here. And so, we'd like to avoid big gaps like
And so, we'd like to avoid big gaps like this cuz they look ugly. Hard to read.
this cuz they look ugly. Hard to read. Now, if you use
Now, if you use uh Microsoft Word,
uh Microsoft Word, at least before the latest versions,
at least before the latest versions, they follow a greedy strategy, which is
they follow a greedy strategy, which is very simple. You pack as many words as
very simple. You pack as many words as you can on the first line, then you go
you can on the first line, then you go to the next line, pack as many words as
to the next line, pack as many words as you can on the second line, keep going
you can on the second line, keep going like that. And that strategy is not
like that. And that strategy is not optimal.
optimal. If you use
If you use uh LaTeX, as some of you have been doing
uh LaTeX, as some of you have been doing on problem sets, and I think also new
on problem sets, and I think also new versions of Word, but I'm not sure,
versions of Word, but I'm not sure, then uh it uses dynamic programming to
then uh it uses dynamic programming to solve this problem. And that's what
solve this problem. And that's what we're going to do here. So, let me
we're going to do here. So, let me specify a little bit more about what we
specify a little bit more about what we mean here.
mean here. Uh
Uh So, the text
So, the text we're going to think of as a list of
we're going to think of as a list of words.
And we're going to define a quantity badness.
And this is a an aesthetic quantity, if you will.
an aesthetic quantity, if you will. I'm going to tell you what LaTeX uses.
I'm going to tell you what LaTeX uses. But um
But um this is sort of the how bad it is
this is sort of the how bad it is to
to use
use or let's say uh yeah.
Words I through J as a line.
So, this is Python notation. So, it starts at I and ends at J minus one.
starts at I and ends at J minus one. That'll be convenient.
That'll be convenient. Um so, I have this list of words, and if
Um so, I have this list of words, and if I look at words I through J minus one,
I look at words I through J minus one, and I think of what happens if I pack
and I think of what happens if I pack them in a line,
them in a line, uh well, they may fit or they may not
uh well, they may fit or they may not fit.
fit. Okay, so there's going to be two cases.
Okay, so there's going to be two cases. Uh, if they don't fit, I'm going to
Uh, if they don't fit, I'm going to write infinity.
write infinity. Cuz that's really bad.
So, I have some notion of how wide my uh,
uh, line can be. And if the sum of the
line can be. And if the sum of the lengths of those words plus the sum of
lengths of those words plus the sum of the lengths of the spaces is small as
the lengths of the spaces is small as possible,
possible, is bigger than the width of my
is bigger than the width of my uh, screen or page, I guess, then I say
uh, screen or page, I guess, then I say they don't fit. And then I define
they don't fit. And then I define badness to be infinity, meaning I never
badness to be infinity, meaning I never want to do that.
want to do that. Uh, that's This is actually LaTeX sloppy
Uh, that's This is actually LaTeX sloppy mode, if you want to be technical.
mode, if you want to be technical. Um, otherwise,
Um, otherwise, it's going to be
it's going to be page width
Why cubed? Who knows. This is the LaTeX rule.
This is the LaTeX rule. Um, and squared would probably also be
Um, and squared would probably also be fine.
fine. So, this is the width of the page minus
So, this is the width of the page minus the total width of those words,
the total width of those words, which you also have to include the
which you also have to include the spaces here.
spaces here. You take the difference, you cube it.
You take the difference, you cube it. And so, when this is small,
And so, when this is small, I mean, when these are very close, then
I mean, when these are very close, then this is going to be close to zero.
this is going to be close to zero. That's good. That means you use most of
That's good. That means you use most of the line. When the total width is much
the line. When the total width is much smaller than the page width, then this
smaller than the page width, then this will be a large value. You cube it, it
will be a large value. You cube it, it will be even larger. So, this will
will be even larger. So, this will highly discourage big gaps like this.
highly discourage big gaps like this. And it will very much discourage not
And it will very much discourage not fitting.
fitting. So, there's a trade-off, of course. And
So, there's a trade-off, of course. And the idea is you might, in the greedy
the idea is you might, in the greedy algorithm, you make the first line as
algorithm, you make the first line as good as you can.
good as you can. Uh, but it might actually be better to
Uh, but it might actually be better to leave out some of the words that would
leave out some of the words that would fit here in order to make the next line
fit here in order to make the next line better. And in general, it's hard to
better. And in general, it's hard to tell where should I cut the lines
tell where should I cut the lines uh, in order to get the best overall
uh, in order to get the best overall strategy. What I'd like is the sum of
strategy. What I'd like is the sum of the badnesses of the lines.
the badnesses of the lines. So, it's a sum of cubes, and that's
So, it's a sum of cubes, and that's really hard to think about.
really hard to think about. But that's what dynamic programming is
But that's what dynamic programming is for. You don't have to think. It's
for. You don't have to think. It's great. Cuz it's brute force.
great. Cuz it's brute force. Okay, so
Okay, so the first thing we need to do is define
the first thing we need to do is define sub problems.
sub problems. This is in some sense the hard part.
This is in some sense the hard part. The rest will follow easily.
The rest will follow easily. So,
So, I think actually it might be easier to
I think actually it might be easier to think about, uh, for this problem, what
think about, uh, for this problem, what would be the brute force strategy? How
would be the brute force strategy? How would you try all possibilities?
would you try all possibilities? Exponential time.
Exponential time. Suggestions?
Try all partitions of the word. So, of the string of words.
the string of words. So, I mean, it could be I It all fits in
So, I mean, it could be I It all fits in one line. I could be it's split into two
one line. I could be it's split into two lines. I try all possible splits there.
lines. I try all possible splits there. In general, I'm guessing for every word,
In general, I'm guessing for every word, does this start a line or not?
does this start a line or not? That would be always. And so, there are
That would be always. And so, there are two to the N. If I have N words, there's
two to the N. If I have N words, there's two to the N different splits. For every
two to the N different splits. For every word, I say yes or no, does this begin a
word, I say yes or no, does this begin a line?
line? So, what I'd like to figure out is where
So, what I'd like to figure out is where those lines begin. That's That was the
those lines begin. That's That was the point of that exercise.
point of that exercise. Uh,
Uh, so any suggestions? Maybe it's actually
so any suggestions? Maybe it's actually easier to jump ahead and think, what
easier to jump ahead and think, what would I guess
would I guess in my solution? If I have this big
in my solution? If I have this big string of words,
string of words, what's the natural first thing to guess?
Guess how long the first line is. Yeah. We know that the first word begins a
We know that the first word begins a line, but where where does the second
line, but where where does the second line begin?
line begin? So, I'd like to guess where the second
So, I'd like to guess where the second line begins. That's
line begins. That's So, you know, I have a beginning of line
So, you know, I have a beginning of line here,
here, and then I have a beginning of line here
and then I have a beginning of line here at the fourth word.
Where does the the second line begin? I don't know. Guess. So, I'm going to try
don't know. Guess. So, I'm going to try all the possible words after the first
all the possible words after the first word,
word, and say, well, what if I started my
and say, well, what if I started my second line here? At some point, I'm
second line here? At some point, I'm going to be packing too much into the
going to be packing too much into the first line, and so I I abort.
first line, and so I I abort. But, uh,
you know, I'll try them all. Why not? Okay, that's good.
Okay, that's good. The issue is that once I've chosen where
The issue is that once I've chosen where the second line is, of course, the next
the second line is, of course, the next thing I want to guess is where the third
thing I want to guess is where the third line begins, and then I want to guess
line begins, and then I want to guess where the fourth line begins, and so on.
where the fourth line begins, and so on. In general, I need to set up my sub
In general, I need to set up my sub problems so that after I do the first
problems so that after I do the first guess,
guess, I have a problem of the original type.
I have a problem of the original type. Okay, so originally, I have all the
Okay, so originally, I have all the words.
words. But after I guess where the second line
But after I guess where the second line begins, I have
begins, I have the remaining words.
What's a good word for the remaining words? If I give you a list of words,
words? If I give you a list of words, and I want from here on, it's called
A sub problem. Yes, that's what we want to define.
to define. Uh, it's called a suffix of the array.
Uh, it's called a suffix of the array. It's the word I was looking for. It's
It's the word I was looking for. It's tough when I I only have one word
tough when I I only have one word answers.
answers. So, my sub problems are going to be
So, my sub problems are going to be suffixes,
which is, in Python notation, I colon. They call it splices.
Sorry? Two to the N?
That would be That would be a problem if it was two to the N.
it was two to the N. I hope it's only N.
Originally, we said, okay, we're going to for every word, we're going to say,
to for every word, we're going to say, is this in or out? Is this the beginning
is this in or out? Is this the beginning or not? That's two to the N.
or not? That's two to the N. But here, the idea is we're we're only
But here, the idea is we're we're only thinking about, well, what are the words
thinking about, well, what are the words that remain? And it could be you've
that remain? And it could be you've dealt with the first 100 words, and then
dealt with the first 100 words, and then you've got N minus 100 left, or it could
you've got N minus 100 left, or it could be you've dealt with the first 1,000
be you've dealt with the first 1,000 words, and you've got N minus 1,000.
words, and you've got N minus 1,000. There's only N choices
There's only N choices for for that. We're only remembering one
for for that. We're only remembering one line. This is the key.
line. This is the key. Even though we may have already guessed
Even though we may have already guessed several lines, we're just going to
several lines, we're just going to remember, well, okay, this is what we
remember, well, okay, this is what we have left to do. So, let's forget about
have left to do. So, let's forget about the past.
the past. This is what make makes dynamic
This is what make makes dynamic programming efficient.
programming efficient. And just going to solve it,
And just going to solve it, uh, solve these sub problems, forgetting
uh, solve these sub problems, forgetting about the past.
about the past. So, the sub problem, I I'm not going to
So, the sub problem, I I'm not going to write it here, is, if I give you these
write it here, is, if I give you these words, never mind the other words, how
words, never mind the other words, how do I pack them optimally into a
do I pack them optimally into a paragraph?
paragraph? I don't care about the other words, just
I don't care about the other words, just the these words. So, this is a different
the these words. So, this is a different version of the same problem. Initially,
version of the same problem. Initially, we have N words to do, now I have N
we have N words to do, now I have N minus I words to do. But it's again text
minus I words to do. But it's again text justification. I want to solve this
justification. I want to solve this problem
problem on those words. That's just how I'm
on those words. That's just how I'm going to define it. This will work if I
going to define it. This will work if I can specify a recurrence relation.
can specify a recurrence relation. Okay, as we said,
Okay, as we said, what we guess
what we guess is,
is, uh, where to break the first line, where
uh, where to break the first line, where to
to uh, start the second line.
For those words. Okay, so this is, um,
it could be the I plus first line, it could be the I
the I plus first line, it could be the I plus second line, or sorry, word. Some
plus second line, or sorry, word. Some word after I
word after I is where we
is where we uh, guess the second word. The number of
uh, guess the second word. The number of of choices for the guess
is at most N minus I. I'm just going to think of
N minus I. I'm just going to think of that as order N.
It won't matter. The third part is we need a recurrence
The third part is we need a recurrence relation.
I claim this is very easy. I'm going to
I'm going to uh, I didn't give this problem a name.
uh, I didn't give this problem a name. So, I'm just going to write it as
So, I'm just going to write it as DP
DP of I.
of I. So,
So, this is going to be the solution to that
this is going to be the solution to that suffix, words from I onward.
And I'd like to What I want to do is consider all
What I want to do is consider all possible guesses.
possible guesses. So, I mean, this is going to be pretty
So, I mean, this is going to be pretty formulaic at this point. After I've set
formulaic at this point. After I've set up these ideas, there's pretty much only
up these ideas, there's pretty much only one thing I can write here, which is I
one thing I can write here, which is I want to
want to do a
do a for loop.
Uh, I think that would be the for loop of where the second line can start. I
of where the second line can start. I can't start at I, because that's where
can't start at I, because that's where the first line starts. But it could
the first line starts. But it could start at I plus one.
start at I plus one. It could And uh, this special value of N
It could And uh, this special value of N will mean that, uh, there is no second
will mean that, uh, there is no second line.
line. Okay?
Okay? So, DP of I, now I want to do this for
So, DP of I, now I want to do this for loop in order to try all the possible
loop in order to try all the possible guesses. J will be the word where the
guesses. J will be the word where the next thing starts. So, then what do I
next thing starts. So, then what do I write up here?
All right, so I have word I is the first word of the first
word I is the first word of the first line,
line, and then word J is the first word of the
and then word J is the first word of the second line.
Okay, and then there's more stuff down below. I don't know what that is.
below. I don't know what that is. But, uh,
But, uh, what How can I
what How can I use recursion to specify this?
DP of J. Exactly.
I guess uh if I'm doing recursion, I should use parentheses
should use parentheses instead of brackets, but
instead of brackets, but if you're doing it bottom-up, it would
if you're doing it bottom-up, it would be square brackets.
So, that's just DP of J. That's the cost of
of the rest of the problem. And I can
the rest of the problem. And I can assume that that's free to compute. This
assume that that's free to compute. This is the magic of dynamic programming.
is the magic of dynamic programming. But then I also have to think about
But then I also have to think about well, what about the first line? How
well, what about the first line? How much does that cost?
much does that cost? Well, that's just badness of IJ.
Well, that's just badness of IJ. And we've already defined that, we
And we've already defined that, we compute it in constant time.
compute it in constant time. Dynamic programming doesn't really care
Dynamic programming doesn't really care what this is, it could be anything. As
what this is, it could be anything. As long as you're trying to minimize the
long as you're trying to minimize the sum of the badnesses, whatever function
sum of the badnesses, whatever function is in here, we just compute it here.
is in here, we just compute it here. That's the power of dynamic programming.
That's the power of dynamic programming. It works for all variations of this
It works for all variations of this problem, however you define badness.
problem, however you define badness. So, you might say, "Oh, that's a weird
So, you might say, "Oh, that's a weird definition. I want to use something else
definition. I want to use something else instead." That's fine, as long as you
instead." That's fine, as long as you can compute it in terms of just I and J,
can compute it in terms of just I and J, and you know, looking at those words.
and you know, looking at those words. Okay, now I need to do uh a min over the
Okay, now I need to do uh a min over the whole thing, cuz I want to minimize the
whole thing, cuz I want to minimize the sum of the badnesses.
So, I compute for every guess of J, I compute the cost of the rest of the
compute the cost of the rest of the problem plus the cost of that first
problem plus the cost of that first line.
line. And this is in some sense checking all
And this is in some sense checking all possible solutions
possible solutions magically.
Okay. That's the recurrence.
That's the recurrence. Uh we need to check some things.
Uh we need to check some things. I guess right now we just want to
I guess right now we just want to compute how much time does this cost?
compute how much time does this cost? Time per sub problem
is I have to do this for loop. Basically, I
I have to do this for loop. Basically, I do constant work, all of this is
do constant work, all of this is constant work, for each choice. I said
constant work, for each choice. I said there's order N choices.
there's order N choices. So, this is order N.
Now, we have to check that there's a topological order
for this problem or for these sub problems.
or for these sub problems. And this is easy, but a little different
And this is easy, but a little different from what we've done before because we
from what we've done before because we have to actually work from the end
have to actually work from the end backwards
backwards cuz we're expressing DP of I in terms of
cuz we're expressing DP of I in terms of DP of larger values of I. J is always
DP of larger values of I. J is always bigger than I.
bigger than I. And so, we have to do it from the right
And so, we have to do it from the right end back to the beginning.
N N minus 1 down to 0. I didn't actually define DP
down to 0. I didn't actually define DP of N. There's a base case here,
of N. There's a base case here, which is
which is DP
DP of N
of N equals 0.
equals 0. Cuz the meaning of DP of N is I have
Cuz the meaning of DP of N is I have zero words, the nth word onward. There
zero words, the nth word onward. There are There is no nth word, it's 0 to N
are There is no nth word, it's 0 to N minus 1 in this notation.
minus 1 in this notation. So, I don't pay anything for the a blank
So, I don't pay anything for the a blank line.
Okay, so that's uh our topological order. This one, of
our topological order. This one, of course, is instantaneous. And then we
course, is instantaneous. And then we work backwards, and always whenever we
work backwards, and always whenever we need to compute something, we already
need to compute something, we already have the value.
have the value. Uh the total time we get
is going to be the number of sub problems, which is N, times the running
problems, which is N, times the running time per sub problem, which is order N,
time per sub problem, which is order N, which is order N squared. And in the
which is order N squared. And in the worst case, it is indeed theta N
worst case, it is indeed theta N squared.
squared. Although in practice, it's going to work
Although in practice, it's going to work better because lines can't be too long.
better because lines can't be too long. Uh so, that's the running time. Then
Uh so, that's the running time. Then finally, we have to check that the
finally, we have to check that the original problem it actually gets
original problem it actually gets solved.
solved. And in this case, the original problem
And in this case, the original problem we need to solve is
we need to solve is DP of 0.
DP of 0. Because DP of 0 means I take words from
Because DP of 0 means I take words from 0 onwards. That's everybody.
0 onwards. That's everybody. So, that's that's the actual problem I
So, that's that's the actual problem I want to solve.
want to solve. So, we work backwards, we solve all
So, we work backwards, we solve all these sub problems that we don't
these sub problems that we don't directly care about, but then the first
directly care about, but then the first one is the one we want, and we're done.
one is the one we want, and we're done. So, in quadratic time, we can find the
So, in quadratic time, we can find the best way to pack lines
best way to pack lines uh pack words into lines.
uh pack words into lines. Question?
DP of J is returning It's like this. So, DP of This is a recursive definition.
DP of This is a recursive definition. Imagine this is a recursive function. I
Imagine this is a recursive function. I wrote equals, which is uh Haskell
wrote equals, which is uh Haskell notation, if you will. But normally, you
notation, if you will. But normally, you think of this is like def DP of I is
think of this is like def DP of I is return min of this. This is Python.
return min of this. This is Python. So, uh it's just It's returning the
So, uh it's just It's returning the cost. What was the best way to pack
cost. What was the best way to pack those lines from J onwards? That's what
those lines from J onwards? That's what DP of J returns, so it's a number.
DP of J returns, so it's a number. It's going to be a sum of badness
It's going to be a sum of badness values. Then we add on one new badness
values. Then we add on one new badness value, it's still a sum of badness
value, it's still a sum of badness values. We return the best one that we
values. We return the best one that we find.
find. Now, this does not actually pack the
Now, this does not actually pack the words. That's a good maybe your implicit
words. That's a good maybe your implicit question. It's not telling you how to
question. It's not telling you how to pack the words, it's telling you how
pack the words, it's telling you how much it costs to pack the words. This is
much it costs to pack the words. This is a lot like shortest paths, where we
a lot like shortest paths, where we didn't It was annoying to actually
didn't It was annoying to actually figure out what the shortest path was.
figure out what the shortest path was. Uh not that annoying, but that's not
Uh not that annoying, but that's not what we were usually aiming to do. We
what we were usually aiming to do. We were just trying to figure out the
were just trying to figure out the shortest path weight.
shortest path weight. And then, once we knew the shortest path
And then, once we knew the shortest path weight, it was pretty easy to
weight, it was pretty easy to reconstruct the paths.
reconstruct the paths. So, maybe I'll
So, maybe I'll take a little diversion to that
take a little diversion to that and talk about parent pointers.
The idea with parent pointers is just remember
It's a very simple idea, but it applies to all dynamic programs and lets you
to all dynamic programs and lets you find the actual solution, not just the
find the actual solution, not just the cost of the solution.
cost of the solution. We did the same thing with shortest
We did the same thing with shortest paths. We even called them parent.
paths. We even called them parent. Uh so, when we compute this min,
Uh so, when we compute this min, we're trying all choices of J. One of
we're trying all choices of J. One of them, or maybe more than one, but at
them, or maybe more than one, but at least one of them actually gave you the
least one of them actually gave you the min. That's usually called the argmin in
min. That's usually called the argmin in mathematics. It's What was the value of
mathematics. It's What was the value of J that gave you the minimum value of
J that gave you the minimum value of this thing?
this thing? So, I mean, when you compute the min,
So, I mean, when you compute the min, you're iterating over every single one.
you're iterating over every single one. Just keep track of which one was the
Just keep track of which one was the best.
best. That's it. Call that the parent pointer.
Uh do I need to write that? I mean, here, parent
parent of I is going to be argmin
is going to be argmin of that same thing.
of that same thing. So, it's It's a J value.
So, it's It's a J value. It's the best J value for I.
It's the best J value for I. And so, we store that for each I. It
And so, we store that for each I. It costs no more work just a constant
costs no more work just a constant factor more work than computing the min.
factor more work than computing the min. We also write down the argmin.
We also write down the argmin. So, we're already storing the min in the
So, we're already storing the min in the DP table.
DP table. DP of I would would get stored to be
DP of I would would get stored to be that. We also store parent of I. And
that. We also store parent of I. And then once we're done,
then once we're done, uh we start with our original problem,
uh we start with our original problem, and we follow parent pointers to figure
and we follow parent pointers to figure out what the best choices were.
out what the best choices were. So, we start at 0 because we know word 0
So, we start at 0 because we know word 0 begins a line.
begins a line. And then, so 0 will be the first line.
And then, so 0 will be the first line. Then we go to parent of 0.
Then we go to parent of 0. That will be where the second line
That will be where the second line begins.
begins. Then we go to parent of parent of 0.
Then we go to parent of parent of 0. That will be where the third line
That will be where the third line begins.
Okay? Because these were the best choices for where the second line
choices for where the second line begins. This was where the best place
begins. This was where the best place where the second line begins given that
where the second line begins given that this is the first line. This is the best
this is the first line. This is the best line where the second line begins given
line where the second line begins given that this was the first line. So, that's
that this was the first line. So, that's really the third line given this is the
really the third line given this is the second line.
second line. Little confusing. But you just do a
Little confusing. But you just do a simple for loop. You start with 0
simple for loop. You start with 0 because that's our original problem. You
because that's our original problem. You keep calling parent of the thing you
keep calling parent of the thing you currently have, and linear time you will
currently have, and linear time you will reconstruct where the lines break.
reconstruct where the lines break. So, you can use this technique in any
So, you can use this technique in any DP. It's very simple. It's totally
DP. It's very simple. It's totally automatic. Just like memorization
automatic. Just like memorization is a technique that you can apply
is a technique that you can apply without thinking. You could even write a
without thinking. You could even write a program to give it a recurse given a
program to give it a recurse given a recursive algorithm, would turn into a
recursive algorithm, would turn into a memoized recursive algorithm. It's
memoized recursive algorithm. It's totally automated.
totally automated. Same thing with the bottom-up DP table.
Same thing with the bottom-up DP table. As long as you know what the
As long as you know what the uh
uh what the topological order is, just make
what the topological order is, just make those for loops, then put exactly the
those for loops, then put exactly the recursive call, but turn it into an
recursive call, but turn it into an array call. Boom, you've got a bottom-up
array call. Boom, you've got a bottom-up algorithm. Totally automatic, no
algorithm. Totally automatic, no thinking required.
thinking required. Parent pointers also no thinking
Parent pointers also no thinking required. As long as you're following
required. As long as you're following the structure of trial guesses, compute
the structure of trial guesses, compute some value, just remember what the guess
some value, just remember what the guess was, you reconstruct your solution.
was, you reconstruct your solution. And that's the great thing about dynamic
And that's the great thing about dynamic programming is how much of it is
programming is how much of it is automatic. The hard part is figuring out
automatic. The hard part is figuring out what to guess, and then what your sub
what to guess, and then what your sub problems are, or the other order.
problems are, or the other order. Whatever works.
Whatever works. Any other questions about text?
I would like to move on to blackjack. Okay. Now, I brought some cards cuz some
Okay. Now, I brought some cards cuz some of you may not know the rules to
of you may not know the rules to blackjack. How many people know
blackjack. How many people know blackjack?
blackjack? Okay, how many people do not? Willing to
Okay, how many people do not? Willing to admit it? A few. All right, so this is
admit it? A few. All right, so this is for you and for fun entertainment. So,
for you and for fun entertainment. So, I'm going to bring Victor up to help
I'm going to bring Victor up to help demonstrate the rules of blackjack.
demonstrate the rules of blackjack. We're going to play standard casino
We're going to play standard casino blackjack as in the movie 21 or
blackjack as in the movie 21 or whatever.
whatever. Uh so, I'm going to just do a random cut
Uh so, I'm going to just do a random cut here, so I can't cheat. Um and you have
here, so I can't cheat. Um and you have a tablet. That's That's scary.
a tablet. That's That's scary. Okay,
Okay, look up strategy. Anything special? All
look up strategy. Anything special? All right. Uh hopefully you do not have
right. Uh hopefully you do not have X-ray vision. Um so, the way it works is
X-ray vision. Um so, the way it works is we There's a dealer, player, and the and
we There's a dealer, player, and the and one or more players. We're just going to
one or more players. We're just going to do it with one player to keep it simple.
do it with one player to keep it simple. I'm going to be the dealer, so my
I'm going to be the dealer, so my strategy is actually totally
strategy is actually totally deterministic. There's nothing
deterministic. There's nothing interesting. Victor has the hard part of
interesting. Victor has the hard part of winning. So, to start out, I believe we
winning. So, to start out, I believe we deal to you first, then to me, then to
deal to you first, then to me, then to you, then to me. So, let's hold up these
you, then to me. So, let's hold up these cards, Victor, so people can see them.
cards, Victor, so people can see them. Uh you don't get to see one of my cards.
Uh you don't get to see one of my cards. That's some peculiarity of the rule. And
That's some peculiarity of the rule. And if the sum of our cards goes over 21, we
if the sum of our cards goes over 21, we lose the game. Uh Victor first. Uh I I
lose the game. Uh Victor first. Uh I I cannot have a value more than 21 in this
cannot have a value more than 21 in this these hands cuz I only have two two
these hands cuz I only have two two cards. You have a value of ace, great.
cards. You have a value of ace, great. An ace can be a one or an 11. That's the
An ace can be a one or an 11. That's the fun rule. So, this is either an eight or
fun rule. So, this is either an eight or an 18.
an 18. And so, Victor has a choice of whether
And so, Victor has a choice of whether to take another card or not. What would
to take another card or not. What would you like to do? The Bender strategy says
you like to do? The Bender strategy says stand. He stands, so he's going to stick
stand. He stands, so he's going to stick to that.
to that. At this point, uh my cards flip over. I
At this point, uh my cards flip over. I have 17,
have 17, which is the same as you, which I
which is the same as you, which I believe means I forget about tie rules.
believe means I forget about tie rules. You have 18. All right.
You have 18. All right. works. So, that's good. I'm going to hit
works. So, that's good. I'm going to hit in the hope that I have a small card
in the hope that I have a small card that will push me right above you.
that will push me right above you. Uh but I do not. I lose. I'm sad.
Uh but I do not. I lose. I'm sad. is to stand on 17. Oh, always stand on
is to stand on 17. Oh, always stand on 17. Uh all right, never mind. You still
17. Uh all right, never mind. You still lose, but Thanks. Yeah, I still lose.
lose, but Thanks. Yeah, I still lose. Game is over. My strategy is always
Game is over. My strategy is always stand on a value
stand on a value Stand on 17.
Stand on 17. less 17 or higher. And if I have a value
less 17 or higher. And if I have a value less than 17, I always take another
less than 17, I always take another card. So, let's do it one more time. Get
card. So, let's do it one more time. Get it right. So, I'm going to deal to you,
it right. So, I'm going to deal to you, deal to me,
deal to me, deal to you.
deal to you. Deal to me. So, hold up your cards.
Deal to me. So, hold up your cards. Uh you have 18 again.
Uh you have 18 again. Are you cheating?
All right. I still have to stand. You still stand
I still have to stand. You still stand according to tablet.
according to tablet. So, I in this case have a 20, and so in
So, I in this case have a 20, and so in this case, I win. All right, so you get
this case, I win. All right, so you get the idea. Each Let's say in each case
the idea. Each Let's say in each case we're betting a dollar. So, at this
we're betting a dollar. So, at this point we'd be even. He won $1, I won $1.
point we'd be even. He won $1, I won $1. Uh but in general,
Uh but in general, uh slight I think it's balanced. For
uh slight I think it's balanced. For these rules, there's a 1% advantage for
these rules, there's a 1% advantage for the house. 1% advantage for the house.
the house. 1% advantage for the house. Interesting. All right. Well, that's
Interesting. All right. Well, that's beyond this class.
beyond this class. Uh what we're going to see is how to
Uh what we're going to see is how to cheat in blackjack.
cheat in blackjack. Okay?
Okay? So, this is going to be
So, this is going to be I encourage you to try this out at
I encourage you to try this out at casinos. Just kidding.
This is a little bit difficult to actually
actually do in a casino unless you have an inside
do in a casino unless you have an inside man.
man. So, if you have an inside man, go for
So, if you have an inside man, go for it. Uh
it. Uh it's guaranteed to win you lots of money
it's guaranteed to win you lots of money cuz it's going to play optimally. In
cuz it's going to play optimally. In perfect information blackjack, I suppose
perfect information blackjack, I suppose that I already know the entire deck.
that I already know the entire deck. Suppose somehow either I get to put the
Suppose somehow either I get to put the deck there or I have some x-ray vision,
deck there or I have some x-ray vision, I get to see the entire deck ahead of
I get to see the entire deck ahead of time. And then somebody's going to play
time. And then somebody's going to play through a game over and over with me,
through a game over and over with me, or not over and over, but until the deck
or not over and over, but until the deck is depleted.
is depleted. And I want to know in each case, should
And I want to know in each case, should I hit or should I stand?
I hit or should I stand? And I claim with dynamic programming,
And I claim with dynamic programming, you can figure that out.
you can figure that out. Using exactly the same strategy as text,
Using exactly the same strategy as text, actually. It's really for each word,
actually. It's really for each word, should I start a new line or not?
should I start a new line or not? Same same problem here.
Same same problem here. Okay, it's slightly more complicated to
Okay, it's slightly more complicated to write down,
write down, but
but um
um So, let's say the deck
So, let's say the deck is a sequence of cards, and I'm going to
is a sequence of cards, and I'm going to call it C0, C1 up to Cn - 1. It's n
call it C0, C1 up to Cn - 1. It's n cards.
cards. And you are one player
versus the dealer. I don't know how to solve this for two
I don't know how to solve this for two prob- two players. It's an interesting
prob- two players. It's an interesting open problem. But for one player,
open problem. But for one player, uh
uh I can do it.
I can do it. Uh let's say
Uh let's say $1 bet
$1 bet per hand, I think they're called. I
per hand, I think they're called. I don't I'm not sure. Per play,
don't I'm not sure. Per play, per box, whatever.
per box, whatever. Um you're not allowed to double, you're
Um you're not allowed to double, you're not allowed to split. All these fancy
not allowed to split. All these fancy rules uh are hard to think about,
rules uh are hard to think about, although you might be able to solve them
although you might be able to solve them as well.
So, the idea is I have some cards. Should I hit or should I stand? I don't
Should I hit or should I stand? I don't know. I'll guess.
know. I'll guess. So, our guessing
So, our guessing Let's jump ahead to the guessing part.
is whether we want to hit or stand given a card.
a card. Um
Um Actually, it's cuz it's a It'd be easier
Actually, it's cuz it's a It'd be easier to think about an entire play, an entire
to think about an entire play, an entire hand. We're going to guess how many
hand. We're going to guess how many times should I hit?
in the first play. So, initially, four cards are dealt. I
So, initially, four cards are dealt. I look at my hand.
look at my hand. Uh actually, I don't really look at my
Uh actually, I don't really look at my hand. I'm just going to guess ahead of
hand. I'm just going to guess ahead of time. Mm, I think I'll hit five times
time. Mm, I think I'll hit five times this time. Uh I think I'll hit zero
this time. Uh I think I'll hit zero times this time. I mean, I'm going to
times this time. I mean, I'm going to just going to try them all. So, I don't
just going to try them all. So, I don't really have to be intelligent here.
really have to be intelligent here. Okay?
Okay? It's kind of crazy, but
It's kind of crazy, but it works.
it works. Our subproblems,
Our subproblems, anyone tell me what our subproblems
anyone tell me what our subproblems would be?
would be? In one word or less?
In one word or less? Less would be impressive.
Yeah. Where do you start the hand? Where do you start the new hand? Yeah. So,
do you start the new hand? Yeah. So, it's going to be suffixes of the cards.
it's going to be suffixes of the cards. So, at some point, you know, we do a
So, at some point, you know, we do a play, and then we get to the ith card,
play, and then we get to the ith card, and then the rest of the game will be
and then the rest of the game will be from the ith card on.
from the ith card on. So, it's going to be suffix
So, it's going to be suffix C I colon, I guess it would be the
C I colon, I guess it would be the notation here. It's a bit awkward.
notation here. It's a bit awkward. These are the cards that remain. And so,
These are the cards that remain. And so, the subproblem is what is the best play?
the subproblem is what is the best play? What's the What's the best outcome given
What's the What's the best outcome given $1 bets? How much money can I make?
$1 bets? How much money can I make? Maximize my winnings, say,
Maximize my winnings, say, given these cards onward. Who knows what
given these cards onward. Who knows what happened to the earlier cards, but just
happened to the earlier cards, but just these are the cards I'm left with.
these are the cards I'm left with. Okay? Number of subproblems is
n How many choices of I are there? n
How many choices of I are there? n choices.
choices. Okay, this is really important. It's
Okay, this is really important. It's really useful that we're thinking about
really useful that we're thinking about suffixes. It's not that some subset of
suffixes. It's not that some subset of the cards have been played. That would
the cards have been played. That would be really hard cuz there's exponentially
be really hard cuz there's exponentially many different subsets that could be
many different subsets that could be left. It's always a prefix that gets
left. It's always a prefix that gets played, and therefore a suffix is left.
played, and therefore a suffix is left. And there's only n suffixes. Remember
And there's only n suffixes. Remember that. Going to use it over and over in
that. Going to use it over and over in dynamic programming.
dynamic programming. So, now uh we need to solve the
So, now uh we need to solve the subproblem starting from CI, what's the
subproblem starting from CI, what's the best way to play? Well, the first four
best way to play? Well, the first four cards are fixed, and then we guess how
cards are fixed, and then we guess how many hits are left. Uh so, it's going to
many hits are left. Uh so, it's going to be something like n - i - four different
be something like n - i - four different possibilities for I mean, that would be
possibilities for I mean, that would be the maximum number of hits I could take
the maximum number of hits I could take all the remaining cards. That would be
all the remaining cards. That would be the
the the most. Um and let's see. So, the
the most. Um and let's see. So, the number of choices,
number of choices, I'll just say it's at most n. I don't
I'll just say it's at most n. I don't have to be fancy here.
Okay. Now, we go to uh the recurrence.
So, I'm going to call this uh blackjack of I is going to be the solution. I want
of I is going to be the solution. I want to solve this subproblem.
to solve this subproblem. From I onwards, what's the best play?
From I onwards, what's the best play? And I guess it's going to be a max if
And I guess it's going to be a max if I'm measuring winnings.
I'm measuring winnings. And what's the winnings if I decide to
And what's the winnings if I decide to hit this many times? It's a little bit
hit this many times? It's a little bit hard to write down the exact formula.
hard to write down the exact formula. I'm going to write a rough version,
I'm going to write a rough version, which is the outcome of that first play.
which is the outcome of that first play. It's going to be either I lose a dollar,
It's going to be either I lose a dollar, we tie,
we tie, or I win a dollar.
or I win a dollar. So, if we if we end up with the same
So, if we if we end up with the same value, you actually use in most
value, you actually use in most versions, you get your money back.
versions, you get your money back. Nothing changes. The bet is nullified.
Nothing changes. The bet is nullified. So, that's a zero outcome.
So, that's a zero outcome. But if I'm only betting a dollar, these
But if I'm only betting a dollar, these are the three possible outcomes. You can
are the three possible outcomes. You can compute this, right? If I told you how
compute this, right? If I told you how many times you hit, then you just
many times you hit, then you just execute that those through those cards,
execute that those through those cards, and you compute the values of my hand of
and you compute the values of my hand of your hand versus the dealer's hand. You
your hand versus the dealer's hand. You see, you know, did anyone bust? If so,
see, you know, did anyone bust? If so, they lose. Otherwise, you compare the
they lose. Otherwise, you compare the values, and you see which is bigger or
values, and you see which is bigger or smaller.
smaller. Okay, this is easy to do in linear time.
Okay, this is easy to do in linear time. No biggie. Uh what's useful here is that
No biggie. Uh what's useful here is that the dealer strategy is deterministic.
the dealer strategy is deterministic. So, after you know how many cards you
So, after you know how many cards you take, what the dealer does is forced
take, what the dealer does is forced because it just looks, do I have 17 or
because it just looks, do I have 17 or greater? If not, take another card, and
greater? If not, take another card, and keep repeating that.
keep repeating that. So, it's a deterministic strategy in
So, it's a deterministic strategy in linear time you can figure out what the
linear time you can figure out what the outcome is.
outcome is. Then you also have to add the outcome of
Then you also have to add the outcome of all the remaining cards, which is just
all the remaining cards, which is just BG of J. This is recursion. Super easy.
BG of J. This is recursion. Super easy. We do this for all choices of J.
Uh it's like, you know, range of I + 4 up to n, I think.
Sure, that'll work. I should probably put in an if here, which is if it's a
put in an if here, which is if it's a valid play.
Okay, there are some constraints here. If I've already busted, I can't hit
If I've already busted, I can't hit again.
again. So, in fact, what you have to do in this
So, in fact, what you have to do in this for loop is say, well, maybe I take
for loop is say, well, maybe I take another hit. Maybe I take another hit.
another hit. Maybe I take another hit. At some point, I go over 21, and then
At some point, I go over 21, and then you have to stop the for loop. So, I'm
you have to stop the for loop. So, I'm writing that as an if. You can also do
writing that as an if. You can also do it with a break, however you want. But
it with a break, however you want. But that's uh
that's uh You consider all possible options, all
You consider all possible options, all valid options of play. For each of them,
valid options of play. For each of them, you see what the outcome was after the
you see what the outcome was after the dealer takes some more cards.
dealer takes some more cards. Uh this is actually a little bit funny.
Uh this is actually a little bit funny. Hm, sorry. This should really be the
Hm, sorry. This should really be the number of hits
number of hits and range from let's say zero to n.
and range from let's say zero to n. Maybe you don't hit at all.
Maybe you don't hit at all. And then J is a little bit tricky cuz
And then J is a little bit tricky cuz this is actually I plus four plus the
this is actually I plus four plus the number of hits
number of hits plus the number of dealer hits.
Okay, so you have to run this algorithm to compute what happened, which computes
to compute what happened, which computes how many times the dealer took a card.
how many times the dealer took a card. That's how many cards got consumed and
That's how many cards got consumed and so that's uh if you do I plus four plus
so that's uh if you do I plus four plus that plus that, that's how many cards
that plus that, that's how many cards are left or where the cards resume.
are left or where the cards resume. And then you call BG on that. So we're
And then you call BG on that. So we're in general from BG of I
in general from BG of I if we think of the DAG
if we think of the DAG in this sum position maybe I plus four
in this sum position maybe I plus four happens, maybe it doesn't happen. It
happens, maybe it doesn't happen. It depends on um what the dealer does.
depends on um what the dealer does. Uh
Uh we're going to depend on I plus six, I
we're going to depend on I plus six, I plus five maybe. It's going to be all of
plus five maybe. It's going to be all of these possibilities. These are all
these possibilities. These are all different plays.
different plays. And then on each of these edges we're
And then on each of these edges we're going to have plus one, zero or minus
going to have plus one, zero or minus one. Those are the outcomes.
one. Those are the outcomes. Whether I won or lost or tied.
Whether I won or lost or tied. And then we're just computing
And then we're just computing a shortest path in this DAG.
a shortest path in this DAG. It's actually really easy
It's actually really easy if you think of it that way. This is
if you think of it that way. This is just how many cards are left. From that
just how many cards are left. From that position you just see what are all the
position you just see what are all the possibilities, what are all the edges
possibilities, what are all the edges that could I could go to? Where could I
that could I could go to? Where could I What states could I go to next? How many
What states could I go to next? How many cards are remaining? How much did it
cards are remaining? How much did it cost me or win me?
cost me or win me? And then take uh longest paths in that
And then take uh longest paths in that DAG.
DAG. That will give you the exact same
That will give you the exact same answer. That's what this dynamic
answer. That's what this dynamic programming is doing. In the lecture
programming is doing. In the lecture notes there's more details where I
notes there's more details where I actually tried to write out this
actually tried to write out this function this recurrence as an
function this recurrence as an algorithm. And you can do it
algorithm. And you can do it assuming I got everything right. It's
assuming I got everything right. It's not that hard.
not that hard. Uh the order here is just the same as
Uh the order here is just the same as the order we did before. The running
the order we did before. The running time is going to be cubic in the worst
time is going to be cubic in the worst case because we have uh it's a little
case because we have uh it's a little non-obvious but we have n subproblems.
non-obvious but we have n subproblems. For each of them we have n choices and
For each of them we have n choices and for each choice we have to run the
for each choice we have to run the dealer strategy.
dealer strategy. And so that conceivably could take
And so that conceivably could take linear time. Here I'm assuming a general
linear time. Here I'm assuming a general value of 21. If 21 is actually constant,
value of 21. If 21 is actually constant, it'll only be constant time to play out
it'll only be constant time to play out a single hand and then it's quadratic
a single hand and then it's quadratic time. So it depends on your model of
time. So it depends on your model of generalized Blackjack.
generalized Blackjack. Uh but that's it and you get some flavor
Uh but that's it and you get some flavor of the power of dynamic programming.
of the power of dynamic programming. We're going to see it's even more
We're going to see it's even more powerful than this in the next two
powerful than this in the next two lectures.